hey everyone its micromotor flows and in
this video I'm gonna be talking about
the order flows turns how to use order
flow to find market turning points and I
want to cover I'm gonna show you charts
from last week September 24th through
September 28th 2018 in various markets
in various time frames and I'm gonna go
over some of the settings of this
indicator now before I begin a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures train
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk couple is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results alright so
what is the order close turns well it's
a tool that analyzes the order flow in a
bar to generate potential market turning
points you know areas in the market
where prices are being supported or
defended and what it looks at is it
looks at order flow and it looks at
technical analysis a technical analysis
more swing analysis and price action so
what it covers is Delta a point of
control overall volume in the bar they
compare as volume traded on the bid
against the ask price action and swing
analysis so in this presentation I don't
wanna make it too long but I'm in
covering several markets in several
different time frames or chart types I
will cover buns euro currency emini is
on a four range on a one-minute and an
eight range you know I don't want to be
covering too many markets because it'll
just this video will just go on and on
but what you know earlier this week on
the last Monday and Tuesday I sent
emails with buns and euro currency and
you know over the weekend I sent out
another email showing you how it
performed how it followed up on the rest
of the week and I want to cover that
really briefly here but I also show you
the e minis you know different range
based charts a4 range in an 8 range as
well as a one-minute chart and I'm also
talk about the setting so first we'll
take a look at the bun so this is the
settings that I have for the buns and
I'll be honest with you majority of the
settings are all the same for all the
markets you'll see
we got short look-back filter on signal
threshold point three volume zero and
the two things that I think that well
the one thing that get a lot of
questions on is what's the difference
between duration there's actually a
short duration and a long duration and a
short duration would be if you're
looking at something like say a four
range chart or a 1-minute chart I would
consider that a short duration chart if
you're looking at say a five minute
chart or an eight range chart I would
consider that long duration and it just
what it does is it differentiates the
type of charts because again you know
when you're dealing with volume I don't
think you can compare a four range chart
in terms of an eight range chart on the
same you know as one is it's a shorter
time frame just as if you're looking at
a thirty second chart
you're not gonna analyze the data the
same way you would analyze a five-minute
chart you know it's it's sort of
different time frames so if it's shorter
duration would be things like a four
range chart or a one-minute chart or
less and a longer duration you know be
five minute chart or a bar chart or show
a range chart that has you know more
than eight price levels or more so
that's the difference in there and the
other difference again they're all
pretty much the same so the only one
that differs on that shorter longer
duration is going to be the eight range
chart which I have changed along you can
see they're also here on the euro
currency it's set to long but the four
range it's all short short the
one-minute chart is short they all got
the same signal threshold point three
look-back period is so you see here
listen look special 0.3 boom point three
boom point three boom point three boom
point three boom and the look-back
period they're all set at seven seven
seven seven except the euro currency
which is set to two because it's a bit
more volatile and when I say volatile
you know you get more price movements
and during the day on an eight range
your own currency chart than you do on a
then a say Europe
sorry mini or or a bunch art but again
you could I could set that to seven if I
wanted to but I've I said it the - I
prefer - I want a few more signals than
than less because I'm trying to get more
it's gonna give you more more signals
but it's also at the same time you know
opens up the door tomorrow losing trades
but the same time it opens up me to more
training opportunities that's why it's
set to seven and the signal threshold
everything is set to 0.3 0.3 0.3 0.3 0.3
0.3 if you set it to say 0.4 it's gonna
be stronger and you gonna get less
trades if you set it to 0.2 it's going
to be a little bit I'll say weaker but
less again it's what it's doing is it's
analyzing volume and order flow so if
you set it to a lower number it's gonna
give you more signals it's letting more
trades in you set at the point 10 even
0.1 rather what you'd be ten percent and
so let's take a look here at the bones
we'll start with the buns here give me a
sec my blend chart up here so again
going back to Monday I'd sent Monday and
Tuesday out on email but you can see
here this red area is in midnight red
it's more of a fuchsia magenta it would
be selling areas binaries are down here
in the blue and it signals at the top of
the bar again you could adjust it if you
if you want that or if you just want an
arrow you know I sometimes I need
something a little bit big to slam in my
face you know you got that cell right up
right up here off the open excuse me um
sorry for that so you got this about
1:30 in the morning
there's set the Chicago time so you got
that nice cell I've got a buy signal
here rallied up then you sort of gotta
sell it just once sideways probably
would have stopped you out then I sell
off and then just comes back into this
area where you're trading back and forth
I'm you got a cell area in here followed
by a buy area in there some price
support market rallied then you come
down in here again market just went
sideways to lower before it rally back
up then you got these or just went
sideways afterwards didn't really rally
but didn't sell off and then the market
closed next day 20
if you got this nice cell signal here
followed by this nice by signal on the
low you got this - selling area up in
here we sold off a little bit about 10
ticks if we came back up this buy failed
here it got a couple of small cells here
followed by this buy right here rallied
up into the cell that failed then you
got another buying signal here I'm not
buying opportunity well this is the next
day already actually so this was the end
of the 25th then on the 26th see got
this nice buy here rallies up I don't
say rallies but you get it's moving
higher but sideways sideways but higher
comes down actually test that low that
you made earlier in this bar you know it
was a Fed day that day I believe on
Wednesday you got this nice buying
opportunity here and market rallied then
going into the 27th was buy that failed
immediately the sell again it came back
up tested these highs here and then move
started moving a little bit lower then
rally back up again this this sign
opportunity failed again I want you to
see the ones that were they failed
started work out and turn around we're
just a few outs then you come down into
this buying area nice buying area down
in here and then you rally up about 15
ticks there another buying area down in
here again you rally up about 15 ticks
there same thing here coming down into
the area of support price support down
here I mean you can sort of just draw
this box out a little bit further if you
wanted to and you can see how it's
holding then boom nice rally going into
the close of the day then on 28 on
Friday what happens you get this nice
buy and right after the open and what
happens is it fails but then about 30
minutes later you get a nice area up in
here of selling area price resistance up
here price defense what happens is the
market sells off quite nicely to an area
of support rallies back up to an area
of intermediate defense intermediate
resistance cells off this one fails I
mean I mean look at this day so you had
one that failed
okay stop topping guys nice tight stop
you know four or five ticks from where
you're getting in then you get a nice
move here from you know 72 all the way
down to 40s you know then you get
another buy buying opportunity to right
down here in the 40s mid 40s rally up
into the mid-60s I've got a sell signal
from the mid-60s all the way back down
into the run down into the 40's rally
back up in here tell me these are 20
tick moves here and look at you know
what's your risk you're risking maybe
five or six ticks you know getting short
here and it stops you out okay but you
just had a 20 tick winner in another 20
tick winner in another 20 tick winner
you know then you come in here later in
the day 4:00 in the morning just before
5:00 again you get another buying
opportunity
and what happens market loose on 150 890
all the way up to you know 159 20 and
then you sell off somewhere hit this
area rallies up a little bit and here
this area rally up a little bit and they
get one more signal here this one didn't
work out there in the end of the day
with that but you mean again
can you are you willing to take you know
this trade here and this trade here to
get stopped out on you know this trade
here you know like even these two little
ones here you could got something out of
you know your rally up to where an area
you know you got price resistance with
the the prominent point of control is
this purple area in here in that point
of control this purple area so you know
it's it's a nice little tool so that's
the settings that I'm using with this
Bund for range chart again this is not
much variation now let's take a look at
the euro currency on the 8 range chart
and on the 8 range chart I said the only
thing different I used obviously that
changed the direction to long because
it's an 8 range chart longer bar
look-back period I changed it to and
there's a reason for that because it's
was around a bit more so where am I here
this is the euro currency the eight
range chart that me starts on 26 I'll
just take it back here a few more days
for you started on on Sunday night that
way you know you can see it for the
entire week I think it's just better for
you to see the whole week rather than
just say oh you know he's only showing
me that times it worked no I want you to
see the times it works times it doesn't
work see see is 25th so here this is
starting on the 24th right here you can
see there gives you something else nice
low here rallies up this area comes off
comes up to this area sells off rallies
back up you got this
selling area up in here buying area down
in here you can see these little cells
cells this one fails this one you got
some bodies bodies buys the small move
here and just you know range trading but
it's giving you the sell on the body of
the cell then you close next day asian
session opens up you got a couple buying
opportunities and you got this nice
salad you know these two just sort of
goes sideways on you then you got a nice
sell here this one fails you know this
one I think I would have stopped me out
cuz you know just poked through there
made that new low you know it sucks but
that happens yeah I move on to the next
trade you know we start moving down
there's then go sideways you know this
one yeah same thing you know it just
comes down stops you out
this one doesn't stop you out you get
then you get that little poke higher I
would have liked to see it take out this
this high on this move it - didn't you
sort of got this little head and
shoulders there then you come down here
you got a nice buy rally up this area we
got a nice sell you just go sideways in
here stop the second one this buy what
it stops you out this one right on the
on the future side on the cash side on
the futures closed right before that
then you come into the 27th
now you know we spent a lot of time
going sideways in here this one failed
this one this by failed the cell I put
it up as maybe you could scratch that or
maybe even take the loss this one got
stopped out on but then BOOM
got a nice trade here another nice trade
here debatable if you've been stopped
out on this one you know this one fight
we're gonna stopped out then you got a
nice move here you got a little move
here here if I would have been stopped
out these two stopped out stopped out
this one you could got something out of
hopefully before it came up there this
buy could got something out of the cell
you could have got something out of then
coming into Friday this one failed you
got something here something here
stopped out something here something
hear something hear something here this
one probably stopped you out these two
stopped you out this one stopped you and
then going into Friday afternoon just
before the futures closed you got a cell
signal but again I wouldn't take that
and hold it through the weekend so
that's you know I this is something I
didn't mention before this indicator
will work on a bar chart as well as a
candlestick chart as well as a footprint
chart so let's go take a look at sorry
that was the euro currency arranged so
let's take a look at the e minis on the
for range chart again short I used to
look back seven signal threshold 0.3 go
to my four range chart here this is
gonna be a footprint chart here there
you go footprint emini z' for range just
go back here to make sure that the right
day here twenty-fourth okay so Sunday
night on the reopen boom within the
first 30 seconds you got to buy that
field then you know after it settles
down about ten after ten after five yeah
nice buy here you got a nice sell there
nice sell here it works out this by were
stopped you out this by here didn't work
out this by again if you're trying to
get a point out the market you got your
point this one didn't work out again you
got your point there this one didn't
work out
yeah you could have got something out of
this trade here got something out of
this trade this one just sort of went
sideways on you could've got something
out of that trade got something here
got definitely got something here I mean
you know this is a four range chart I
mean you know you're talking to move
from twenty nine twenty two and a half
down to nineteen again got something
here again look at this move from twenty
nine twenty five and a half you know
down to twenty nine twenty one you know
it's four points that's the low of the
day right there again another nice
little move here this one didn't work
then could have got something here you
know you're talking not one point or one
tick you're talking you know from thirty
five down into the you know thirty-two
area this buy doesn't work out then you
get another buy down here look at this
you know again from the twenty five area
all the way up to twenty nine area this
buy fails then you're going into the
cash close here you got to buy you got a
sell you got to buy it could be if
you're scalping right if you're just
looking for the next few ticks you could
be getting it right there then this is
the evening session on the next night
this is going into the twenty seventh
the selling area up in here okay so you
say you get stopped out on this one I
don't think you would have so I like to
I draw these little buffer zones up in
here above the bar these are the areas
like the danger zone like telling me hey
you know if you're training in here be
careful if we're gonna poke through it
get out that's if you like to use manual
stops you know stops in your head then
you gotta know there's a nice cell
signal right up in here I mean look at
that 29 you know fourteen fourteen and a
half all the way down to you know nine
nine and a half then you got a nice buy
here you know got a nice little move up
up up up the cell doesn't work out this
by works out nicely you got a nice cell
in here this cell just goes sideways on
you then you get a nice buy here I mean
look at that when you're talking to most
rate up move you know over you know the
next half-hour or rallies from six and a
half all the way up to thirty and a half
we got the cell then just goes sideways
on you that would have stopped you often
you get a nice cell here this by fails
on this by fails this by it starts to
work out and just hangs wrong goes
sideways on you again you should
recognize when a trade is not working
out I mean it's easy to see that you
know this trade didn't work out but when
you're in a trade like this you got a
look at the signs that it's not working
out and you know some of the signs
obviously look at the Delta house II
look at what the bars are doing you know
I mean doesn't take a rocket scientist
to say hey you know I started to rally
no Sun I'm looking at a bunch of red
bars that that's not a good sign you
know I should think about getting out
especially if you got strong negative
Delta what you knew you got - a thousand
- 1250 you know before it falls over you
know then again you got another couple
cells right in here this is the evening
time on the coin into the twenty-eight
look at that imagine you're selling that
they're just around midnight 2923 was it
- it sells all the way off down to your
new low down here you got a divergence
and a ratio right on the low of the
night of the day at that point you know
from twenty three all the way down to
sixteen seventeen area the cell doesn't
work out in the cell you know this would
have stopped me out in all honesty this
one just sort of goes sideways on you
but again you should be able to
recognize what's happening you got red
candle doji one green and red you got
mostly selling in here at all negative
Delta it's time to get out don't sit
there wait for it and pray and it's
going to come back to you here similar
thing you know you got this you know if
you're long ago I'm gonna give it a
little bit more time than you're staring
at this prominent point controlled is
big red you know those red candle with
this magenta pointing controls telling
you hey you know what this trade might
not work out you come down in here and
what it stopped you out okay then it
made the move but still recognize what's
happening you should just be happy to
get out and just look wait for the next
trade to come along next trade comes
along hopefully could have got you know
a point or two out of that one this one
sim
same thing just starts going sideways
again if you're short you know you're
short here hey Austin you looking a
green candle green candle strong
positive Delta 1400 you know what just
get out I mean if you if you can scratch
this trade I don't think you could
scratch this trade you would have at
best lost maybe a half a point you know
be happy with that and just wait for the
next trade the next trade comes along
you're selling up here at the high of
the day 29 24 and a half and look at
that it just keeps moving down down down
you know maybe you cover it down in here
on 22 and a half or two and a half
points now maybe you hold it again I'm
not saying you'd get out down here but
you know realistically I pie would have
been looking to get out in here but then
if you're watching the order flow and
you see you got a stacks on imbalance in
here maybe you're not gonna get out
maybe so well you know I'll just give it
a little bit more time then you'd be
hopefully rewarded ok next selling
opportunity comes in here again the
29:20 area all the way down to 29 2018
29 18 for a lease back up to the 21 then
you get a buy in here just sort of go
sideways a little bit higher you got a
sell here it makes a little bit move
down then it rallies back up there so
then as you come into the cash closed or
sorry the Friday's close again you get
this little buy here is a little sell
here but again you got to recognize
what's going on right if you're long
here right if you're long off this trade
and you see signs in here are stacks
selling imbalance that's not a good sign
if you're long right and you see a
prominent point of control again you got
a signal kicking off but even if that
signal wasn't there if I'm staring at
this stack selling a balance and a
prominent point of control you know I'm
not thinking I should still be long
right just as if you get short here then
you come down in here and look you've
got you know a stack behind and balanced
well don't think that oh we're just
gonna it's gonna fail and we're gonna
keep going down you gotta be watching
what's happening in the order flow I
mean that's the that's why you use order
flow you know if you have a sign up here
in the order flow you know the turns is
giving you a signal that hey you know
there's there's price defense up in here
market sells off a couple points then
boom when we hit this area you know this
is a bullish ratio telling you a price
support then you
stacked buying and balancing here you
got aggressive buyers boom boom boom
that's the sign you know what was
happening here is fine that's in the
past that's ancient history but if
you're watching it happening in real
time then you're short and then you also
and you see conditions changing in the
market you see Nasdaq buying a balance
he got the aggressive buyers coming in
you've got the bullish ratio down here
it's telling you hey you know what it's
time you know to get out of that trade
rather than wait for it to come all the
way back up here and stop you out or you
know break even on their trade get out
now then you go into the close and
that's the the closed for the day all
right so that was the four range start
now let's take a look at a minute page
chart because you know not everybody
likes to trade on an arranged based
chart some people like to use a minute
based chart and again say the settings
are the same you know one minute look at
this short you got the tick they're 7.3
as I use your short tick they're 7.3 so
it's not like you know I'm sitting here
jumping around with changes all the time
it's it's very similar very it's like
the same let's go back sure I got this
set up except eight just so it goes back
to the beginning now this is a 1-minute
chart so it's gonna be a lot of data but
just give it a second here okay so just
go back to the beginning here so make
sure check the date time stamp here the
24th okay so let's take it back to the
sunday opening from last week so we've
reopened
all right Sunday night we have to
scrunch it down a bit so it's a little
easier to see and let's just go through
it here so you know the thing is with
the 1-minute chart
you know you get periods like this right
I'm not a big advocate of training on a
minute pace chart I do look at them and
you know it's but some people you know
that that's what they swear by and okay
I mean I want you to see how the
indicator looks on here
so the
I don't know necessarily care for a
minute base charge so much is because
you get periods of inactivity like this
at certain times of the day is how the
markets move around and if you're just
looking at the market trading bid
against the offer a bid offer a bit off
or a bit off for a bid offer for
extended periods of times it's not
giving you much information to make
trades off of but you know we'll wait
till it's starting things start picking
up here here you got a buy signal what
happens the market just goes sideways on
you you know that's that's what happens
sometimes especially Sunday night during
Asian hours I mean during the day
session is really where things will pick
up but just actually starts picking up a
bit during the European session but
still not so much sometimes here's a
sell just once sideways on you but again
you know that's you're just trading at
this time bid against the offer but
against the offer there's little cells
sold off a little bit not much here's a
buy just went sideways on you but you
know once 8:30 kicks in my once the cash
opens and you're gonna get some real
activity so you can see hey are now 8:30
now bars are looking normal right the
rest of the whole morning you're just
looking at crap like this that's why if
you're training on a minute patient
aren't you just better off training
insuring the cash hours rather than you
know around during the night
session so nothing yet here's a cell
that didn't work here's a buy just once
sideways on you get another buy it just
one sideways on you there's a sell
sideways on you there's a buy started
you know it's slowly grinding up but
again you know excuse me mmm some water
you know for some people they like to
see they like the Train on a minute pace
chart because they know at 59 seconds
one second later the bar is gonna close
and they can sort of manage their trade
that way for something III can see that
I understand that but I'm not a big fan
of it you know but you know this is a
nice little trade here here's a nice
little trade there here's a buy and then
a sell here that fails then you're going
into the cash
closed futures close reopen the next
night again it's just it's you know when
you train a minute pace charter in Asia
it's just it's sometimes it's really
like watching paint dry and is really
extremely frustrating because you want
to do something sometimes you know you
want to be doing something and you still
see the screen flashing especially
looking at a dome you still see numbers
changing you thinking oh my gosh I gotta
do something I do something and
ultimately you do something wrong so
let's just go into the next day here
European session you got this cell here
you see it sold off and you know it did
it sell off yeah it sold off from 29 28
and a quarter down to seven and a
quarter again it's a one-point move I
mean it's okay it's nothing to build
your career on but again I want you to
see how it looks on out on a 1-minute
chart okay so here you're coming into
the cash open this is by one or two
minutes before the cash hold me got a
nice sell signal here cash open and we
sold off nicely about three points you
know before you rally back up and sell
off again the sell started sell off and
you sort of went sideways sideways
sideways there's one is a cell that just
went sideways on you this by failed you
know this it just didn't work out sell
just want sideways on you again you know
I find it in trading right you're what
you're doing is you're trading price
movements you're not training time based
price movements and that's why I prefer
arranged based charts here's a minute
base so here's a here's a buy that
didn't work out right for the cash close
after the cash close you know by just
once sideways on you before started
rallying up like a point or two asian
hours the next day this is the 27th or
28th yeah that's what's the 25th so
again to the 26th
this speeded up a bit more you know
here's a bye then too much did something
but not much
it's another bye just went sideways
there's no the by one sideways 8:50 in
the morning
cell started selling off rally back up
got another cell signal sold off a
little bit so by just sort of went
sideways on you before putting in the
little rally here these are just stacked
imbalances in here the cell you know
over the next couple minutes yeah it
sold off and rallied back up I mean this
was what are you talking in here you
know move from 11 and 3/4 down to 10 in
a quarter so only about a point and a
half can you know I'm not a big fan of
trading on a minute page chart but again
you know a lot of people do I'm not
saying that it's right or wrong it just
it depends on on your way of trading you
know and do a video later I'm gonna do
and what type of trader you are here's
one right on the European open or just
after 1:00 a.m. Chicago time it's nice
rally you know I you know here's a cell
here we started selling off than just
one sideways on you sold off some more
this by just ordered one sideways before
it rallied up there's a nice little buy
here rallied up came back in and rallied
up some more
here's a nice buy right after the cash
open cash open over here at 8:30 this is
839 next two bars you know you got this
nice move up from 14 and a half all the
way up to you know eighteen and a half
here's a nice little by just sort of
what sideways sideways and pops up and
then sort of continues that moves back
up you know here's one we rally up come
off a little bit
take about two or three tics of heat
before rallies another four or five
ticks these cells just go sideways on
you and then you got nice by here a nice
cell here just one sideways over one two
three four bars before it started to
move lower the cell just went sideways
on you spy just went sideways on you
this by you know you were taking about a
point loss on that knot here next bar
these are the bars you like where as
soon as you get the signal the next bar
boom this by didn't work out just went
sideways before it failed again same
thing here then the next night here
reopen this is right on the cat the
future is closed here then the reopen
the next day is right in here and we
just move it's kind of a boring video
but I want you to see this you know I
want to show it to you so you can make
the decision if this is a useful tool
for your trading or not here's a nice
cell right on the the European open this
body doesn't work the cell doesn't work
but again you know you printing on where
you're placing your stop you know you're
risking you know what four tix there
four tix there one point no this one
just gonna go sideways on you yeah
hopefully you could've got something out
of this trade and maybe got I don't know
this one thing break-even at best this
one hope you could have got something
out of that for started going sideways
then you know going into the cash hours
the cell doesn't work just was sideways
on you the cell doesn't work we're
stopped you out you got a nice little
buy here the cell doesn't work just by
you know just unfortunately went
sideways here you know you got this
little move up then just one sideways on
you before it fell over but again you
know if you're getting long in here at
11:31
ten minutes later you're just going
sideways I'm not sure I'd still be
looking to hold it at that point you
know you're looking for the move to
happen over the next couple bars not
over the neck on a one-minute chart not
over the next couple hours you know here
again you're talking one minute two
three four five six before I start
selling off whereas over here and you're
getting long yeah it's going in your
favor but then you know after ten
minutes it hasn't moved yet and it's
just sort of hanging around comes down
test your entry price just hanging
around
you know don't expect that it's gonna
make that move you know just look for
the move to happen sooner rather than
later you know I wouldn't be getting
short in here then holding it all the
way down in here no you know at the
first break here is where you'd be
looking to cover you know like this you
know I'm looking for that move over the
next couple of bars next two or three
bars first start to make a move and not
just sort of hanging around and going
sideways that's why I'm not so much a
fan of minute phase charts you know
you're looking for look at this the next
one two three bars right we sell-off
from 18 and three quarters down to you
know down to seventeen seventeen and
three quarters just about and that takes
us to the close alright so the last
chart I'll show you can I don't wanna
keep this video too long I will show you
the e-mini eight range chart and just go
back here so this is starting out 23rd
that's the eighth range chart so the
difference on the setting is I use a
long duration but still you know a seven
period look back and a signal threshold
of three okay you have a buy here it
starts to work out then just go sideways
got another by here so you pair up these
two buys and look at that and you can
get this nice rally from 20 all the way
up to 26 nothing on this day you know
there's just no signals this buy fails
this buy could have got something out of
you know it's two bars up third bar
started going up four reverses
the cell mm-hmm doesn't really work out
you sort of get the signal then just
start going lower than going sideways
you know that's not a good sign if
you're short look to cover it then you
get this nice cell in here again from
the other 13 13 and 1/2 area all the way
down to oh it the cell starts to work
out then you got it running to this
prominent point of control you know you
got some support in there if you reading
the order flow and then you rally back
up eventually gets topped out again you
know it's about understanding what's
happening in in the order flow if you're
short and you see you see information
that tells you you know buying is coming
into the market don't sit there and try
and fight that you can you cover it and
then look at this you know because what
you want to do right you want to take
your loss or take your small profit or
breakeven on the trade like here you
could have hopefully you know scratch
that trade at least and save your
bullets for the next trade you know the
next trade comes along look at that look
at this move from 29:29 all the way down
to 29 19 no those are the these are the
trades that's gonna make your bottom
line make your P&L explode you know then
you get another buy down here the next
day look at that from 11:00 all the way
up don't really get any signs to be
getting out you know even here starts
coming off but then you know it run into
some support in here and you go back up
into here yeah I probably a little
worried in here so okay here your long
from eleven eleven and a half all the
way up to sixteen seventeen in here okay
that's nice five-point move I mean what
I like to say you know you'd cover it up
in here no you know I'd see some signs
in here sort of got this double top in
here some bearish signs and the order
flow I would have covered I mean this
one is very bullish bar in the order
flow with all these imbalances and the
bullish ratio but still you know when
I'm looking at it when it's like this
when you see that bar it doesn't look
very encouraging that it's going to
that's going to keep going up at this
point it's not till the next part comes
in that sort of the races that fear but
you don't know it at that time this bar
is forming and then it rallies up then
coming into the column
Friday afternoon 2:20 yeah bye signal
and just sort of goes around sideways on
you too until the close so one thing to
keep in mind with this indicator is it
runs on ninjatrader 8 there's no version
for a NinjaTrader 7 so don't be thinking
you're gonna get one it's only for a
NinjaTrader 8 and version 15 if you're
not on the most recent release of
NinjaTrader 8 you can just go to their
website and upgraded I give you
instructions on a different video on how
to how to get on the most recent version
a NinjaTrader 8 it's free to do so you
know if you think this is something
that's useful in your trading go to find
out more about it go to order flows calm
slash turns out HTML and I hope to see
you on the inside I'll be doing a
special live group training session this
Friday October 5th at 7 p.m. central
time for users of the software where
I'll be talking about certain different
markets I'll say certain but you know
different markets different timeframes
why certain some changes you know why
some settings will be changed just as
you know why like for example I'll talk
a little bit more about the look-back
filter on why some I use it too and
majority I use it on seven and I'll be
going into using the volume thresholds
which I think I have been showing you
there but this is more for uses of it
where you know it's it's gonna be very
important you know depending on the
markets that you're trained you know
markets like a minis you know that
trades a lot of volume it's not gonna
matter so much because it just puts
through a lot of volume but if you're
trading thinner markets Nasdaq or mini
Dow is it's gonna make a huge difference
by using a volume threshold and I'll be
talking about the volume thresholds that
I use as well as using Delta you know
the ones I showed you here don't use the
Delta I I have it unclick there but I'll
be talking about that as well you know
it's it's all about finding better
trades and you know more higher
probability trades so you know again it
that presentation is gonna be specific
for users of the software so if you
haven't got to go to order flows
turns.com slide H is the slash HTML that
water flows turns.com
slash turns order flow stat
/ turn HTML and you'll see more about
the software there so thanks everyone
have a great day bye-bye